No huddle, Nico. No, that wasn't, that was terrible. You know what I mean?
And they look back at it and then why don't we hire that guy and whatever they
say, Oh, I hate that. Right. So I go in like a Tom cruise blow up,
or do you ever like really, dude, what do you think of a, his blow up?
I respected it. He did it for you,
literally. Like nobody has a blow up and only positive.
Ha like
[inaudible] gets angry and doesn't curse. And just as positive things,
if he dropped like an end bomb in the middle of it, I'd be like, Oh, okay.
This guy really?
He just was the best guy. Yeah. Like we're,
we've got to save people's lives and their college education.
I think that was a PR move. Yes. But,
but that's just because I think that, you know,
his thoughts have dropped since the whole David Miscavige thing when he keeps
doing these big action movies,
but he's really kind of out of the Oscar contender kind of. So I think,
I think that was his attempt to kind of.
Galvanized support in the industry and they make him look like a good guy.
Like he came to work on me. Exactly. Because you really care about Corona.
I'm immune. So I'm like you.
But he, he,
he used his power and that's when you know,
he has power because if I would have done it, this is what,
this is what it would happen. This is what, what happened. Right. Hey guys,
I'm going to tell you right now. And then somebody would go, you.
And it's the gopher. Right? The guy holding the boom.
Boom, you. Sit down. You Chinaman. Right. And I'd be like, Oh, I'm sorry.
Right. Whereas they let Tom go, go,
and I'm going to say this last mission, impossible movie. He did bomb.
Do it. One of the best action moves I've ever. He's a beast. He's a beast.
He's a weirdo. But he's a beast though. Yeah. That's the thing,
like if he was funny, he probably be one of us.
Like, he's weird enough to be one of us. He's just not funny. No, but you know,
I have to admit he was in Tropic thunder. He thought he was really acting. No,
but he was funny. He was trying to be funny. I thought he was, they were like,
seriously be this. We need you to be that guy. Yeah. Yeah. He is a weirdo,
but you know what, dude, it just, just shows us his power. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Yeah. You could probably do that on your new Netflix show.
right. Good. Yeah. Is it a show or a special, what is it? I mean,
it's an hour special that we broke up in four episodes.
So it's like 15 minutes each. Right.
And there it's what you were doing on Instagram, Instagram literally. Yeah.
And then they, they put it on Netflix. Yeah.
We just filmed like longer versions of it. Yeah. The last time you were here,
we were, that's so much about Netflix, bro. I had to,
but now I know how it works. That's how it works. How do you get laid.